All right, hey guys, let's see here.
I think we're live, all right, all right.
Let's see, this lets me go to here, awesome, okay, all right, cool, hey guys, let me put
the link for the zoom here, and then I got to hop on my phone real quick and do the everyone,
so just give me a second, there's the link for the zoom, yeah, let me go here, give me
a second, yeah, there we are, yeah, okay, I think we are, yeah, all right, all right,
I think we are, we're there, all right, cool, yeah, okay, cool, all right, what's up guys,
how's it going, hope everyone's doing well, yes, let me make sure, sorry, give me a second,
okay, we're good, all right, awesome,
let's see, okay, cool, all right, zoom is open, if you guys want to hop in,
we can get over and get some ad questions taken care of, and we'll go from there,
all right, okay, we got a few people here, are you guys seeing the, for the few people
that are watching, are you seeing the links, sometimes the Facebook interface and the zoom
are really delayed, so I just want to make sure, I see them on my phone, but I'm not necessarily
seeing it on the desktop version, someone can, I think there's only a few people watching,
if you guys can just let me know, that'd be awesome, thank you very much, appreciate that,
all right, well, while we're waiting for people, let's go ahead and take a look,
oh, we got someone hopping in, it's like Zach is hopping in, Zach, are you there?
Yeah, I'm here, hey, what's up, man, how you doing? I'm doing pretty good, and you? Good,
oh, not bad, not bad, what can we help you with, do you have any questions for today?
Yeah, I know you guys went over this in like the last few zooms, I think, I don't know if there's,
it's with the ranges in the ads and the keyword list, I'm still getting ranges, so, I'm in the
US, but I've made an MCC account, and I linked my sub account to it, and on that sub account,
I've ran an ad in the past, and I've spent something like $200 on it, so, yeah, I'm just
wondering how to get that, to not show ranges anymore. Okay, is the ad active right now?
It was active in November, I paused it sometime in December, but I resumed it maybe last week,
a week or two ago. Okay, and when you're under, when you're on Keyword Planner, are you under
that account, under that ad account? Yes. Okay, and it's still not showing the ranges for you,
huh? Yeah, like it is showing the ranges, but like not specifically, you know. Okay, would you like
would you be able to share your screen so I can take a look? Yeah, I believe so. I'm kind of getting
the impression that so many more of you guys are having, what group did you come, did you come from
Shib's group, or did you find this group? Yeah, I did. Okay, it seems like everyone from Shib's
group is having this issue, so it's very odd, so I'm trying to figure it out as well, but I think
I'm trying to figure it out as well, but I think some of it is,
so there's been, I just saw the other day that there's a new, there's some changes in the
interface on Google that's like not showing clicks and impressions as much. I don't think
they're, I don't think it's just a glitch as well, so there's some stuff happening. My point is like
there's stuff happening on the Google ad interface right now, and we're not like fully aware of what
they're trying to do yet. We're all trying to like, what are you guys doing? So, I don't know. So,
okay, yeah, let's try to go to, let's open up Keyword Planner. Let's see what happens here.
Okay. Yeah, so this is my sub account I have here. Click it.
Concrete.
Okay.
Yeah, this is what I've still been getting.
Okay. All right, and this is, did I make seen this right? Ann Arbor,
Michigan for the term concrete. All right. Let me, give me, give me a second. Let me,
let me pull up mine and let me see. Let me see what I'm getting. Again, I think this is,
I don't know if this is like a glitch in the system. I don't know if it's Google trying to
like mess with, you know how like they have like the $1,000 spending limit now, and I don't know
if they're doing it. I just, I don't know what they're doing lately. There's definitely some
interface and platform stuff going on. All right, let me, I'm going to click one here.
Click one here.
Because I think when I had the ad ring in November, I could view it.
Yeah. Well, I'm going to see right now. If I'm getting Ann Arbor, Michigan, right?
About 538,000 people. Okay. Concrete. Get results. Let's see what I got here.
Getting, not even a spreadsheet showing up. Hang on. Let me hit refresh.
That was really weird. It like loaded, but it didn't load all the way. So let me try to redo it.
Give me a second.
Hmm. Okay. So I'm getting a really weird, can you scroll up on the spreadsheet on your end there?
Or is that the top? That's the top. Okay. Give me a quick second. Let me see what I got going on here.
There's mine.
There it goes.
Yeah, mine's showing, don't leave your platform. And let me, I'm just trying to go back and forth
between my window and yours. So mine's showing the term concrete at 110.
It has no, it just tracks search volume, but there's no CPC data for it.
Even concrete contractors, concrete companies. There's concrete repair. That's the only one that
I have a CPC for. So let's look at this again. That's the same for mine.
That dollar amount. Yeah. But I'm seeing like that's a 20 for me.
Okay.
Okay. Go ahead and scroll up on the spreadsheet.
I'm not sure why you're not seeing the same thing. Okay. So I'm running this on
a really, really old smart campaign that Nick used to have that we're not running ads on.
It's still a active campaign, but it's like, there's nothing running on it at all. So it's
like, there's no, it's an active campaign, but the ads are paused. Does that make sense?
So it has the same green like circle you do. When in the keyword planner, I hit concrete,
I hit Ann Arbor. I'm showing this, right? Yours is not showing that.
Okay. And then here's the spreadsheet. And this looks like the same thing, like 764 words, right?
Yeah. Yeah. And you can very clearly see that I'm getting concrete concrete.
You can see the exact search volume.
So why are you not is the question. And this is in Nick's MCC. And I'm using
one in a whole different state, like system old smart campaign.
So, I mean, there's nothing, that's nothing special about it.
Um, was, was that a campaign that's like already been ran before maybe
this one was, but he, I don't think this campaign has been active for like three years.
Oh yeah. It's still, I mean, there's, it's an active, it's still left,
but there's no active ads running. Yeah. Yeah. I'm not sure if it was something like
it's grandfathered in compared to this is like a brand new one or what I just set up like
four ads for different clients. Um, this last week, brand new ads, no problem using this.
So I'm not sure why, why you guys are having this issue. It's something I haven't figured out why
yet, but it's something with, um, the people from it's like something in their setup. I can't figure
out what it is yet that you guys are getting from, um, in ships group, like how you guys are setting
it up. Um, I'm not sure why yet. Um, again, it could just, it could just be like all of my accounts,
like I've spent well over a thousand dollars, like, um, you know, Nick's like one and a half million.
Uh, I'm, you know, I'm in the several hundred thousand dollar range. Like,
so I don't know if it's just that it could be that and it's like a new platform thing. Um,
have you used, um, Ryan's, uh, let me see if I can get to it. Uh, rare rare. Yeah. Have you used that
yet? I haven't yet. Okay. Yeah. I highly recommend it. Um, so I'm still like in the beginning of
using it, but like, watch, I'm just going to do States. We're going to do
Michigan. We're going to do a few of the videos, uh, yeah. Is that promoting it?
Yeah. It's pretty cool. Um, like it's got a lot of the niches built in.
Okay. Let's see here. Um, keyword planner and then we're going to do, I totally clicked the wrong
one here. Sorry. So let's see what it shows. So this is like, this is kind of where,
like, my brain is at right now with this for you guys. Um, let me, let me share my screen again.
Okay. So, okay. So I just went in, I just did concrete, Michigan, Ann Arbor, right? And it's
like, here's your, that's a good one. Um, and then we're going to, we're going to, we're going to
Okay. So, okay. So I just went in, I just did concrete, Michigan, Ann Arbor,
right? And it's like, here's your, that's exactly what I saw on keyword planner.
Um, it doesn't give a CPC, but you see this, how there's like, this is your, are you familiar with
like keyword difficulty, a KD rating? Um, not a whole lot. Okay. It's just, it's just a,
some of the platforms use it as a metric to try to tell you like very easy, medium,
or super difficult keyword to rank for. Um, and when you see this PPC thing here with a number,
it's very similar to that. It's basically, they're just doing a quick, like it's, it's right here.
It's low, medium, or like really high competition, right? So this tells me that there might be some
ads running, but it may not be enough for it to like really pick up the other data that you're
wanting to find. Okay. Um, but then like, you can see, you know, it kind of, I just did one word
and it populates a lot of these other ones, right? So it's like concrete companies, concrete
contracts. So there's search volume here. Um, you know, I only see like, remember we saw the
concrete repair was the only one that we saw that for. Um, so it's definitely something to
see what this is. It's, it's, uh, look at this. Um, yeah, you can see like in the warmer months,
there's more searches than the colder months. Um, and that might be why it's not picking up CPC
right now. That could be why, because it is cold up there. Um, so my, my thing right now for you
guys is like this, this tool allows you to do like track tasks. You could do due diligence on it.
Um, you can, you know, put things in, you can keep track of things in your clients, like leads,
phone numbers, like it's a pretty bitching tool. Um, I haven't messed with the backlink analyzer
yet because that's still new, but, um, I think this is like the path forward for you guys.
Honestly, it just, it just, it seems to simplify things. It's less spreadsheets. It's less manual
stuff. It kind of is like a one-stop shop for what we want to do. And it allows you to go really
fast and at scale. So, um, I'm still trying to figure out how to get my VA on it. Um,
and, and maybe get her off of like using main goals and SIM rush and all that stuff. So I
may have her go full time on rare just to see if it's faster for her to do so.
And when it doesn't get like CPCs that pick up on that, is that like a
keyword you should not be like targeting as well?
Uh, so yes and no. Like if you're looking at Michigan, like you saw in one of those,
like it dropped off to like 10 in the cold months and you can see it pick back up in the warmer
months. So that, that doesn't mean that there's no ads running. It just probably means there's
not a lot of ads running right now. Sometimes when like search volumes really low, it doesn't,
it just doesn't aggregate the data up. It doesn't mean that you shouldn't run an ad on it.
Or if you go like to a warmer city and try to maybe use that term, you might get better results
right now. Like if you go somewhere in Florida right now, um, you may see more, like even a
like-sized city. I mean, that's a, that was like what 538,000 people. Um, that's one of those,
like if you go back way back in the group, you'll see people like I did my research and CPC was this
and three months later it's like this. And it's like, well, yeah, it's warmer. There's more people
on the auction market. Like, so, you know, there's, there's, there are fluctuations in the data.
There's fluctuations in the marketplace, right? But, uh, like right now searching in a cold place
for concrete may not give you the best results because sometimes that data that Google is
giving to you is like within a couple of like, it might only be two or three months of data
and may not be like forever data. Right. So, and you'll see that like, you'll see that in like,
let's say you're, you're running ads at say, like, say you start and it's like 650 click.
And then in the warmer months, it's like double that. And then you'll notice again, in the colder
months, it goes back down. So if you stay in certain niches in certain areas, you'll see kind
of cycles, but it's just the thing where, you know, it's why we, you know, we, that's why we
want to look at our ads and make adjustments and we go through them and we look at things and,
oh, what is, what is my, what is it telling me this bit is versus what is my set limit at? And
sometimes you have to fluctuate with that, uh, depending on the weather, really.
So that makes sense. I appreciate your help.
Yeah, no problem. But yeah, I think I'm not sure why you guys, it's, it seems like, I don't know
if we're getting all of our new students from shifts group, but all of you guys are having the
same problems. I'm not sure if it's like, maybe you set up Google ads or your Google keyword planner
a certain way, and it's not recognizing that ad, but I've had other students where we did that
and it worked fine for them. So it's just not working out for everybody. But I'm also,
I'm not like a hundred percent there, but like I mentioned, I'm seeing stuff on the interface
that is like not showing data the way it normally would. And it's like, you have to like go and like
manually open columns. And so there's something going on with the Google ads platform is what
I'm getting at. So I don't know if they're like silently doing an update. I don't know if they're
doing some backend stuff. And so our user end is not looking correct right now. I don't know if
this is going to be a permanent thing, if it's a temporary thing yet, but I'm kind of, I'm kind of
going towards, because right, like Google, like, okay, Google is the largest advertising agency,
like in the world. Okay. So they want to make money. They've been losing money for years. So
they're doing things to try to make more money, but their biggest, the biggest thing they kind
of like guard against is fraud. Right. And so, so like one of the, like one of the barriers to entry
now is like, you have to spend a thousand dollars in ad spend to be able to like quote unquote,
like run an MCC or be able to set up sub accounts in your MCC. That's something that's about a year
old now. It was like, now, like now everybody faces that, or for like the first five or six
months of that, it was hit and miss. Now it's like, that's just, that's, that's how it is for
everybody on the platform. So my point is like, they change things sometimes, and sometimes
they'll do certain things for certain features to make the barrier enter it harder or higher.
And part of that is like, because if, if I have you run ads for a range, if I'm Google,
and then I wanted to get you on a call with one of my people, my salespeople,
who I call a Google expert, they're just trying to, they're going to want to set up your ad for you
and run it for you. They're just going to spend all your money and they don't really care that you
make money on it. Right. They're just want to get your money. So that there could be something like
that happening on the Google ad platform. I'm not sure yet, but I'm thinking that this,
we may be seeing that. So we'll have to change how we like kind of do our setup. And so thankfully
for us right now, rare is available and it's working really well. And I've ran, I've ran dozens
of like, look at rare data and look at keyword planner data. And it is almost always spot on.
Sometimes one of the search terms is like 10 or 20 off, but that's more just because like
the API that he's using to pull that data in is probably a month older than what like actual
keyword planner data is. So you might have a month where like search volume increases,
but it like, it hasn't caught up to the API feed that he gets his data from.
So that, but that gets a small discrepancy. And when I've seen it, I can look at it and go,
oh, I know why I can see it. I can see the data difference. And then if I, I'm sure if I go back
and check it, his will get updated the next month. So I think it's just like a little
month delay reporting, but it's, it's been super accurate as far as like for our needs,
as far as that. So I think that that's like the place to, to start doing this stuff out for you
guys. Pretty spot on. Yeah. Yeah. It's been great. I mean, I'm, like I said, I'm, I'm, I'm trying to,
I'm trying to like build a process and then, and build like a kind of like a training video and
like a, like a, like a step-by-step thing. Cause my VA knows main goals really well.
And she, she knows keyword planner. She knows how to like double check with keyword planner when she
has a maybe. But, you know, using how I, how I've been doing due to her, I've had her doing
due diligence using that and rare has been giving me the same info and it's all in one place. So we
don't have to like have multiple tabs, multiple sheets. It takes away a lot of like a lot of time.
Like that's why I have a VA doing it for me now, because it's worth it for me to have them do it.
So I'm not bogged down for hours doing due diligence, but with rare, like if I was just,
you know, by myself, I would rather use that tool because it does all of the stuff for me in one
place. Whereas, you know, how I have it done now, it's like, it's multiple steps on different
software and then we put it into place. So anyways, I'm trying to kind of streamline my
thing so I can now train her how to use it. So that it kind of makes me, it makes sense to her,
but I'd probably get that done like later this weekend or something. So.
Yeah, that makes sense. I wonder why the ads accounts like that, because I had a Google
Keyword Planner through Shiv's group and then it got it suspended. So I made a new,
I used a new Gmail for this one and it's still not working for this. So yeah, it's pretty confusing.
Yeah. Yeah. It's just what it is. I don't know. It's just Google being Google. I wish I could
tell you it was something easy, but like I said, Ryan's thing has done pretty awesome.
And I think that's where you guys should like probably go to.
Okay. Well, I appreciate your help, Jay.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. I couldn't solve it anymore, but like I said, I think that's the
issue there. So. Yeah, no problem. I think so.
All right, man. Cool. All right. Take care, man.
Yeah. I'll see you. All right. See you.
All right. Okay. It's just me again. I think we have a few people watching.
Anyone wants to hop in? The Zoom link is there.
For some reason, the chat on my desktop is not caught up on the Facebook. So give me a second.
Okay. I'm going to see if I can like send this to see if this helps like pop it through.
Oh, I see why it's doing it.
Okay. All right.
Let's see if I can go here.
Okay. All right. I am seeing it on my other window. So, okay. We'll just kind of go with that.
So if you guys have any other questions, let me know if you guys want. We have the Zoom open.
I'll kind of leave the Zoom open. And if you guys don't have any questions,
I will start running through some of the DMs I got this week and we can go from there.
Okay. And just like a thing for everyone that's new and listening or seeing the replay of this,
I try to be very, I try to check into the Fix It paid ads account at least twice a day.
I'm pretty consistent with that, just so you know. But like if you guys leave me a DM
and I don't respond and say like, try to give me 36 hours-ish, if you don't hear back from me,
don't be afraid to like just get on the DM and say, hey man, just wanted to see if you got this yet.
So, and I just say that because like sometimes, like say I've got my full-time job and
things are getting busy. Like I may see your question and I recognize your question and I'm
like, well, that's going to take like, you know, that's going to take like, I need to spend some
time. That's not a quick answer. Basically, it's not something, oh, do this or do that. It might
be something where I have to kind of like go sit, think about it, or maybe pull up some info for you
to share with you or try to go find something in the group or something to share with you.
So sometimes like that may happen and it's just, I get distracted or busy. It's not that I'm
forgetful. I just got busy and forgot to get back to you. So just don't be afraid to send back. But
I'm pretty good about trying to get right back to you guys when I can. But I just want you guys to
know that. And at the same time, if you leave me something and I reply back to you, like,
and you don't reply back for like two weeks, don't, when you come back in two weeks looking
for something, don't expect me to jump on and get things going. So let's see. Okay.
Okay. He got that. That was just access issue.
Let's see. Oh, just, hey, I get things like this. Just so you guys know, like people call,
like your people will send me messages and say, like, I'm getting phone calls for my ad,
but there it sounds scammy or people are saying that they've called someone else or it's whatever,
like, just know that like we all deal with that. There's like, you know, there's captcha that you
can do for like to try to reduce like the form span. There's, you know, you can do like the IVR
with like press one or press two to talk to somebody. And that helps like reduce some spam,
but like the sophistication of spam is like, they're always like steps ahead of like the
defense mechanism. So just, just understand that like we all deal with that. And so just,
just kind of take that for what it is. Like, just, just know that like, you're not the only
one going through stuff when that happens. Okay. All right. And anybody that's watching,
if you guys want to hop on to the Zoom, the Zoom link is in the comments. If you have any questions
you want to go over, we can go over your stuff. Let's see here. And then, you know, I don't know
how many times we've got to repeat this, like, stay out of large cities. Like, just don't do it.
Please don't do it. Once you get like experience and you are very confident and you're making money,
you know, then there's ways to like eke into it and niche down and, you know, get better with
your locations and ad groups. And you have to set up multiple location pages and service pages.
Like there's ways to do it, but like, don't jump into it. Don't like, like don't jump into Houston.
You know, like don't, that's, that's not, you're just going to, until you have the experience to
do it, like, you're just going to piss away thousands of dollars. And if you think you're
going to hop into a big Metro market for $5 a day or $5 a click at $20 a day, like you're not going
to make any money. You're not going to have any business owners that are going to be happy with
you. So just take our advice and don't do that, right? Small, smaller cities, like keep it
manageable. Well, once you get experience and you understand this stuff and you can read the data,
that's when you can maybe start doing those bigger city areas. Okay. Some of you guys,
really just a couple of you, like, it seems like every, every couple of weeks I get a message and
you're trying to find a place and it's a constant like, well, don't, don't do that. Okay.
Let's see. Todd, Todd hit me up. Yeah. Todd, if you're here, let me know. I know you had some
questions. Let's see here. Let's see. Is anybody on the zoom? No. Okay. Let's see. We got,
okay. Sarah. Oh yeah. We, we got Sarah square away last week. Okay.
This is something you get this recommendation on and other training. You get this recommendation
from Google is like conversion tracking. Um, on your Weebly one-pagers, to me, there's really no
reason to do it at all. Um, if you set up a full webpage, a full website, and you want to put it
on certain triggers, you can do that. Um, I personally don't think it's worth a big hassle
to do it. Um, the value I see in it is if I'm setting up ads for like someone else's website,
then I might spend time to do it so that it kind of like, you know, uh, how I use it as a way to
kind of like, quote unquote, like show value to them. Um, at the end of the day though, like, um,
like, like my client's phones are ringing and they're getting forms or they're not like, I don't
really care about the conversion stuff unless I'm into some very competitive markets or like high
population areas. I don't really care. I just want the phone ring and I want forms to come in. So,
um, you know, if, if I am doing stuff in like LA and Orange County, um, I got a guy in our land,
I got a couple of people in Orlando right now. Uh, I have somebody in Miami for them. I have,
and it's just, it's for me, um, it's, I'm using it in a way to like,
um, focus on areas that we're getting wins at and then not, um, and then kind of like
be able to like shut down stuff where we're not getting wins at, if that makes sense. So
it's just one of those things. Um,
yeah, somebody wants to buy my leads from me in the group. I understand, but all right.
Okay. Yep. That's caught up. I think there are some more pretty simple stuff.
So, uh, with that, I'm going to hit refresh here, see if there's anything new. Sorry. Um,
okay. Let me see. There's any new comments. I don't see any. Cool. Does anybody have any other
questions or anything? The zoom is open. I'll leave it open for a couple more minutes. Uh,
it looks like there's just a few of you here watching. I don't know who's watching, but
if you guys got any questions, type them in the comments, um, or, uh, hop on the zoom and then,
um, yeah, let's see here. Yep. Yep. Yep. Okay. Cool.
All right guys. Uh, so I guess they're in short and sweet today. Not a lot of people on all good.
For those that are having issues with your Google, um, keyword planner stuff, I highly,
highly, highly recommend that you guys get the rare software from Ryan Dalton. You can reach
out to him directly. I believe there's a discount for digital landlord members right now. I thought
I caught that on Nick's live, I believe, or a post that he did. Um, anyways, we'll just hit
up Ryan. He'll help you out, get you set up there. Um, I've been using it. Um, you know,
I'll start like we just showed earlier with Zach. Um, it's been working really good. So anyhow,
all right guys, uh, let me check zoom one more time. I don't see anybody here. Cool. All right.
You guys have a great one. Uh, take care. You know, if you guys have any questions later, bye.